cision le cas de montfermeil maintenant
c'est finalement le 6 janvier prochain
que l'on saura si le maire divers droite
de la ville pierre bernard supprime les
crédits de fonctionnement aux deux
écoles maternelles ou des enfants
d'immigrés avaient été inscrits contre
sa volonté le dossier jean marc
morandini 21h il ya soir la préfecture
de seine saint denis publié un
communiqué dans lequel elle affirme que
le maire de montfermeil a décidé de
revenir sur sa décision
désormais il acceptera dans ces écoles
tous les élèves immigrés c'est un
véritable coup de théâtre dans ce
conflit qui oppose depuis plusieurs mois
pierre bernard et 2 directrice de
maternelle
le maire avait en effet décidé de leur
couper les crédits municipaux
elles sont coupables à ses yeux d'avoir
accepté des enfants d'immigrés dans leur
école
apprenant la reculade du maire hier soir
sur le plateau d'apartés jean marie le
pen réagit il parle de capitulation a
capitulé devant la pression qui s'est
exercée sur lui
mais ce qui vient de s'arrêter à
montfermeil naître ailleurs puisque la
france ne pourra pas faire face à au
phénomène qui consiste à faire rentrer
chaque année 250 mille étrangers nouveau
mais ce matin monsieur bernard affirme
avoir simplement donné deux mois de
sursis au gouvernement pour résoudre le
problème de l'immigration
deux mois durant lesquels il suspend
toute sanction l'unité la préfecture et
où très ambiguë si c'est le préfet lui
même qu'il a donnée où il était mal
interprétés je voudrais demander aussi
bien avec compatriotes à fin mai que la
vessie concitoyens de m'enfermer avec à
mes compatriotes de france de ne pas
croire à un abandon de ma part
certainement pas au contraire nous
allons nous prendre deux mois nous aussi
pour élargir au maximum le mouvement et
au delà de beaucaire et de crèche les
petits immigrés de montfermeil pourront
donc faut tourner en maternelle dès le 9
novembre
le maire leur accorder deux mois de
sursis chat